jake sullivan que es el asesor nacional
de seguridad dijo entre otras cosas que
eeuu está dispuesto y está presto a
enviar material y enviar elementos a
ucrania si rusia avanza militarmente en
ucrania precisamente jake sullivan dijo
que si rusia quiere seguir viendo gas
pasando por el gasoducto nord stream
tiene que evadir la invasión a ucrania
también dijo jake sullivan que pues ese
de como un conocimiento que eeuu esté
haciendo ejercicios militares en la
región báltica y apoyando precisamente a
ucrania no solamente eeuu sino los otros
países de la otan asegurando dijo jake
sullivan las capacidades necesarias para
que ucrania pueda defenderse y asegure
su soberanía desde resaltar también que
el jueves yo bailé en el presidente
estadounidense hablará con el presidente
ucraniano volodomir selenski
cristóbal y cuáles son las reacciones en
el congreso estadounidense sobre esta
esperada videollamada
precisamente el director del comité de
relaciones exteriores el latinoamericano
robert menéndez dijo que ésta era una
amenaza de guerra de acción militar por
parte de rusia y se mostró completamente
en contra de esta dijo que ni los
ucranianos ni la el pueblo ruso querían
en realidad un conflicto militar
simplemente para satisfacer el ego de un
dictador como vladimir putin es de
resaltar también lo que dijo él manuel
macro el que resaltó que después de esta
llamada entre el líder ruso y joe biden
líderes de inglaterra e italia alemánia
y francia se reunieron precisamente para
tener una reacción conjunta y dijo
manuel macrón que estará dispuesto a
mediar para desescalar y para asegurar
la soberanía de ucrania